before we begin
i wanted to get on my soapbox just
briefly address uh youtube
who will be listening to this and
you know i apologize for the last video
for the the last attempt at blundering a
piece
um being pretty vapid and devoid of
constructive content but i i did want to
say that
you know the
philosophy behind the speedrun videos on
youtube is to break them down
into digestible
digestible chunks
and i would much rather err on the side
of having a shorter video
than cramming in four or five games
and i think i would caution people
against thinking that just because the
video is longer that means that you
necessarily learn more
or that uh you know or that it's it's a
linear correlation between the length of
the video the number of games i play and
the amount that you learn learning
doesn't work that way in my opinion
and so i would ask for everyone's
patience you know some of these videos
are going to be a little bit short some
of the games are going to be shorter
some of them are going to be longer i
don't control that
um and i want to give you the speed on
in its raw form rather than curate it
and edit it into unrecognition so
that's just how it is sometimes with
that being said
let's get started and let's try to
blunder a piece but let's do it a little
bit
uh in a little bit of a smarter fashion
than we previously did
[Music]
now let's start e4 we'll start with
normal theory
and then at some point we'll veer often
and blunder
there we go yeah we're facing a sicilian
okay so we're gonna start with an
allopin like we usually do we're gonna
we're gonna start normal
and then we're gonna blunder something
okay so
we're gonna play d4
which is
theory
e6
okay now
i'm gonna make one more developing move
knight c3
probably i should have done bishop g5
that would have been a great opportunity
to blunder because now he's probably
going to go knight f6
and
he won't permit me the opportunity to do
that again
whiz thank you for the 13 months
bishop g bishop b4 okay this is the
great opportunity
that we have i'm going to go bishop g5 i
feel like it's a pretty believable
blunder
um okay looks like i'm developing a
piece at least
the funny the hilarious thing would be
if he doesn't take the bishop
um that would be hilarious
but i think he will i mean 1400
should understands
[Music]
this is a 15-minute game if it was a
bullet game i understand all right
take my pieces
please god i never thought it would be
so difficult to blunder a piece
who knew this is one of the hardest
things to achieve in chess and now he's
oh okay so he's played bishop takes c3
now i think he'll take my bishop
okay yes we got it attempt number two
and we've made it even harder on
ourselves because i have allowed him to
trade another pair of miners now let's
get serious that was funny let's get
serious let's start the recovery process
okay
this is very difficult we're down a full
piece
we've traded on another pair of miners
and the first thing to get out of the
way
is that the movie five does not win the
night back okay the movie five does not
win the night back this and everybody
should know why this is a concept that
even as a total beginner you should be
aware of um and black plays the counter
attack h6
and if bishop drops back to h4 then
black once again attacks the bishop with
g5 unpinning the knight if the bishop
drops back to g3 then the knight is free
to move because it's no longer pinned
but what people but some people don't
always realize is that after e5 h6
um white has uh in certain situations
this being one of them a very
interesting attempt to complicate the
game so i'm going to play e5
yeah so yeah h65 doesn't really ruin
black structure it's uh it's a little
bit weakening but since we're down a
piece weakening is not enough we need
something more concrete we need to
complicate the game in a more uh in a
more
how should i put it
um you know
we really need something more complex
than just inducing a small weakness
that's not going to cut it
so what am i thinking about here
yeah greg connor got it so i'm thinking
about playing he takes f6
okay well black's gonna play h takes g5
and then we take on g7
now that's not the end of the story
because if you calculate one move
further you will see that black plays
the move rook g8 and at first sight it
may seem that
we cannot defend the pawn on g7 we can't
defend it directly but we can try to
defend it indirectly who sees how who
sees a tricky move after rook g8 in that
position very good we can play queen h5
we can play queen h5
and if the rook captures the pawn
then we're going to have a fork with
queen h8 now obviously black doesn't
have to take on g7 there but insofar as
recovering from a blunder
you know
i want to emphasize this straight away
the recovery rarely happens
uh over the course of one move you have
to build up the tension you have to
complicate the game
and you have to sow the seeds of doubt
in your opponent's mind make make your
opponent believe
uh that
that he or she is going
is starting to go wrong uh
and is is making more weaknesses in
their position he takes f6
let's go for it i mean this is really as
good an option as any
now we play f takes g7
and we just want to sew a little bit of
doubt
in black's mind with a move queen h5 and
maybe he'll take on g7 straight away
uh that's also possible that's a pretty
typical blunder but i think at this
level he will probably play the correct
move which is queen f6 queen f6 gets the
queen out into the
into the game and prepares to take the
pawn on g7 with the queen okay he found
it of course that's a pretty obvious
move and that's okay uh because we have
created
something resembling a you know a
weakness on the king's side we
put ourselves in a position where later
on if the king side were to open up yeah
we might have certain attacking chances
now i'm talking about the king side
opening up but right now the king side
isn't really open we have a single queen
here but the queen alone is not going to
create any significant problems
for black we need other pieces now you
might say okay well that means we need
to develop our knight and knight f3 is a
pretty pretty reasonable move
but i think that we can play in a more
tricky way i think that we can open up
the king's side and try to involve the
h1 rook which
uh is you know has more meat on the bone
than knight f3
yeah h4 for the boys that's exactly
right
let's throw in h4 and for the girls
and uh we're posing black with a dilemma
and that's really all that you can do
when you're lost when you're down to
peace another technique that you can use
in order to
get back into the game and try to induce
mistakes is pose your opponent
confront your opponent with decisions
people hate decisions and when you force
your opponent to make several decisions
in a row
um there is such a thing as decision
fatigue where with every subsequent
decision that's a thing and i think
psychology
uh your ability to make further
decisions diminishes
and again you're causing your opponent
to feel just a little bit of doubt in
his ability to win the game
okay well g takes h4 obviously we don't
take with the queen that would offer a
queen trade and be counter-productive we
want to take with the rook and get this
rook into the game maybe later we can
lift it to f4 right now there's
absolutely nothing that we can do we
need more pieces in the game okay now
this is another another opportunity that
we have to complicate uh the game
because
what is black currently threatening well
what does black want to do here
well black wants to take on g2 that's
right and so a lot of people here would
and i'm sure some of you guys are
thinking well let's play g3 well you're
not going to recover from a piece down
uh if you play moves like g3 because
that's not creative enough it's too
straightforward and it's too predictable
you want to find something unpredictable
and interesting
uh and the most important thing is that
this knight is out of the game we
literally don't have any minor pieces
left we cannot afford uh to have our
only remaining minor piece falling
asleep so the question we want to ask
ourselves uh and i call this the sam
shanklin question what happens if you do
it anyway what happens if we just ignore
the pawn on g2 and go knight f3 well
let's consider that and you guys are
already indicating the correct follow-up
move if black takes on g2
we have not lost our castling ability we
can castle queen side that gets the last
piece into the game and guess what that
position looks a lot more complicated
that position looks as complicated as we
can possibly get it if black reacts well
in that position we're going to lose the
game but this is the best that we can do
so at least we can generate oops
and i i'm sorry i met i mixed up the
movie when i was talking about castles
and i played it first and this is a
mistake
uh this is a mistake because it allows a
queen trade i'm sorry about that
i had a little mental
mental snafu
yeah this is uh this happened to one of
my opponents in a classical game
uh which resulted in a peace blower i'll
show you guys afterwards but that's okay
we move on
this does complicate things and i really
hope that he will be enticed by queen
takes g2 then there will be no harm no
foul
but if queen g5 check happens that
results in an end game and that's going
to be incredibly hard to recover from
jesus rip
yeah i mean i was just talking about
castles long and i forgot that we didn't
play knight f3
uh this is a big big moment queen g5
check essentially wins the game not that
not to say that we won't continue trying
i will pull every single gm trick out of
the book i promise you that
i will make him work for it
nope it does not go for the queen trade
it goes 97.
the problem folks is that 97 is also an
excellent move i mean the knight heads
over to g6 or f5
that's just a phenomenal defensive move
probably not even worse than the queen
trade
but at the very least it gives us the
opportunity to develop our knight and
avoid the queen trade which is really
the most that we could possibly ask for
here knight f3 okay at least we keep the
queens on the board i feel a little bit
better here yeah gm's don't die easily
so hopefully it makes sense what we're
doing so far we're trying to complicate
the game uh obviously we're trying to
generate chances against our opponent's
king
which is really the only thing that we
could possibly do in such a situation
um and and hopefully that ultimately
gets gets our opponent nervous bishop b7
how should we proceed
how shall we proceed well this is a very
unfortunate situation for us
because if we play the obvious move
which really is 95 centralizing the
knight
yeah unfortunately we let black trade
queens again
and you know that's just something we're
going to have to roll with because if we
don't go 95 we don't play that
black is going to capture the knight and
without any minor pieces i really feel
that our chances are going to be a lot
less than our chances in the end game
because in the end game we will have an
active knight and we will have an h file
and that's already quite a bit of stuff
to work with and we could still generate
tactical ideas even without queens on
the board i'm pretty confident of that
i'm pretty confident of that so
even after queen g5 check i feel like
we're gonna have
uh
reasonable chances to to pose problems i
i already see an idea
i mean i know it sounds ridiculous but
this is really what i want to show with
this game even if i lose it that
you know the magic of chess is that even
in these absolutely lost positions
if you play in a purposeful way if you
uh if you do stuff specifically aimed at
making your opponents task hard
and you don't shoot yourself in the foot
you're going to pull out a lot of these
games rook c8 hitting the pawn on c3 now
this is a pawn that i think we have to
defend
uh by the way rook ca does uh
black from castling which is a little
bit somewhat encouraging
well we want to defend the pawn but we
don't just want to defend it with a move
like king b2 or c4
some of you guys are proposing king c2
but you know that doesn't squeeze the
most bang for our buck we have to get
bang for our buck we have every single
tempo is golden so if we're defending
the pawn we better bring another piece
into the game
and as i'm saying that you are very
correctly indicating that i think rook
d3 is the best practical chance how does
that bring another piece into the game
well it prepares to lift the rook to g3
and guess what if we get that rook to
you theme we're going to have all of our
pieces on the king side and that is
going to be nothing to sneeze at for
black
so let's go rook d3 again notice that
queen takes g2
uh is possible but very dangerous due to
queen takes f7 check
we are allowing a queen trade but the
idea that i spoke about previously still
persists after queen g5 i still have an
idea and there we go
so we have to take
now here's the idea what do i see here
i feel like our only chance is to
somehow use our knight and get it to one
of black's weak squares maybe to d6
ideally our knight would somehow find a
way to land on d6
now rook h8 is czech itis that's a
completely empty check because black
just covers it with his rook rook hey
check just rook g8 and you're only
throwing oil onto the fire
uh by
saddling yourself with a potential rook
trade
knight c4 blunders the knight that would
be great but it blunders the knight
how else can we possibly get this knight
from e5 to d6 well we can get it through
c4 unfortunately that's not possible we
can also try to get it through f7 knight
f7 knight d6 well we can't play knight
takes f7 that blunders the knight what
we can do is try to attack this pun on
f7 and try to trick him get him to go f6
and then swing our knight through d7
through f7 to d6
it will take a miracle now there are a
couple of ways to try to do that rook f3
blunders the rook don't forget about the
bishop folks rook f4 is not the best way
to do that because black can just
advance the f pawn and that's the
problem with attacking a pawn from the
front you often want to attack a pawn
from the side because that
it's a lot harder to stop knight f7 here
than it is after rook f4
now unfortunately there is
uh an immediate refutation for black
which i see in which i'm hoping he
misses and at the at the end of the day
that's all that you can really hope for
i'm hoping that he plays f6 here
if i have the right understanding of of
this level
i think we have a non-zero chance of
pulling out a miracle here
yeah bishop b4 unfortunately bishop b4
is the move
the game is still not over after bishop
before we still have another chance
you guys see it obviously because i
mentioned it but put yourself in his
shoes he doesn't know that this move
exists necessarily
i'm really hoping for f6 the time
control is also not our friend
it's such a such a long time control
that
and he's got all the time in the world
to find the stuff yeah the likeliest
thing is that we lose this game i mean
there is only so much that i can do
uh down a piece if somebody's playing up
to a decent level there
you're going to lose
but uh we're still hoping
okay like i said i have a pretty good
understanding of how people at this
level tend to think
and this is exciting knight f7 here we
go
now we're getting somewhere and here's
the thing if he goes bishop before now
saying okay well now i'm going to take
one of the rooks no no no that doesn't
work anymore because we get our knight
to d6
okay now what should black do here
what should black do here
no king fa the rook is hanging
guys the rook is hanging
rook d5 rook d5 is the move here for
black because that moves the rook away
and it defends the d6 square but guess
what
what is the drawback of the move rook d5
well let's think about it it moves the
rook away from the g file
well do we have a piece that can
potentially exploit that drawback and it
can access the g-file we do we have a
rook on d3 that could move to g3 and
create
possible ladder-made ideas which will be
impossible straight away because there's
a knight on e7 but you can already see
that storm clouds are beginning to
gather around black's king even though
it's the end game
rook hey check blunders the knight rook
hey check with blunder the night no
that's not rocket chain
in order to be able to play rook h8 we
would need the other rook to be on g7 we
would need both rooks defending the
knight so that one of them
uh could relinquish its duties and move
on to greener pastures e dog oh yeah
after rook d5 if i get out of the pin c4
is a potential idea yes that's true
although there is a rook on c8 that's
that would be guarding that square now
this is exciting because you can already
sense that our opponent is
i wouldn't say starting to crumble but
definitely feels a bit of fear he
probably sees this and this and players
under 1500 they tend to get and i don't
mean this in a demeaning way but
i'm sure those of you in the chat who
are in that rating range
i feel like at least from my experience
with students they tend to get
overwhelmed when there is more than one
threat and when there are
you know when there are very scary ideas
like 96 these big threats can become
overwhelming and can cause panic and
subsequent blunders
and if you're on the reverse side of
this if you're playing black here it's
very important to try to nip that in the
button to basically break the position
down into its component parts where
exactly is the danger coming from if you
ask yourself that question in that way
it becomes less overwhelming well where
is the danger coming from it's coming
from three different sources
the first is that the rook is hanging
the second is that knight d6 is a
massive threat both of these can be
solved with the move rook d5 that
everybody should see
the third source of danger is that all
of a sudden the king has become
has become a serious weakness
um and that'll talk about after the game
but knight f5 he decides to defend the
d6 square but not move the rook away
obviously we should take the rook and at
least we win back some material we are
still much much worse here but at least
we're getting somewhere
okay now how do we think about this
position well
let me take a second and think about it
myself
i have an idea
i have an idea
okay
so i think a lot of you are probably
tempted by the move g4
if i if i understand the chat you're
probably tempted by the movie g4 not a
bad move not a bad move at all
uh chasing the knight away from what is
definitely a very good square g4 is one
of the top candidate moves
um
now after g4 the knight's gonna move
back somewhere probably after g4 the
knight is going to move back to e7
and then we could swing this rook back
around to h3
preparing some sort of h-file battery
that would be a very interesting
approach
but i think i have a way that we can
improve upon that idea
i think i have a way that we could
improve on that idea even further
the way that i'm thinking about this is
rook h a check would win the rook
if it weren't for the b7 bishop right if
this bishop was somehow distracted from
b7
this would win the second rook
um
with supreme rook h3 doesn't actually
threaten anything because rook had king
e7 or h7 the king can escape to d6 it's
less dangerous than it looks
now can we entice black to move this
bishop away from b7 do we have at our
disposal
something to bait black's bishop with
we do d5 but the point of d5 is not just
to distract the bishop that's not the
only thing we're doing
we are doing something else that's very
important which is that we're opening up
the position and if black plays e takes
d5 look at how much black's position is
weak and the knight loses its defender
which enables moves like rook f3 to be
played previously that was impossible
because the bishop controlled that
square
in addition we opened up the e file
which means that after the knight moves
away from f5 rookie 3 check could be
dangerous as well
but what if black ignores us what if
black does nothing
what if black makes a random move
what threat does d5 actually pose
and in order to answer this question you
have to notice the x-ray
yeah we're threatening to take on e6
quite simply and after d takes c6 the
bishop on b7 hangs along the seventh
rank
causing more problems
posing decisions
and i feel like if i again if i
understand my opponent correctly this is
the moment where he might panic and
blunder
i'm sensing that we might see a blunder
in this position by black
whether it's bishop takes d5
or not seeing d take c6 playing a move
like rook c5 i could see that too
no he takes d5 is not the only move i'm
sure there are several possible moves
there's the move e5 here which is also
very good
and yeah it's possible that our opponent
plays e5 as well i wouldn't be
shocked if that happens
i wouldn't be shocked if that happens
but that that is still a very
encouraging sign even if that happens
yeah that in game is holdable but after
e takes d5 we will not play rook takes
d5 that's unnecessarily fancy we want to
keep both rooks on the board
okay i i was proven wrong correctly
playing e takes d5 but it took him a
while to play that
okay let's not lose lose our spirit
well we have several ways to proceed
here
but i i'm sensing a very interesting
idea that i feel like could put us over
the edge
now i feel like we should play g4
because i want to have the possibility
of giving a check on e3
and i also have a secondary idea that
i'm not going to reveal just yet
although you guys can start thinking
about what what you think that might be
it starts with g4 though so let's
everything all the good things in life
start with the move g4
black's move is essentially forced he
has to go to d6
do you guys see what will happen if he
goes back to e7
if he goes to e7 as human
correctly points out there's rookie
three
pinning the knight from two different
sources and winning the knight
and after knight d6 we are going to
execute that secondary idea of the move
g4
if somebody can guess it i'll be pretty
impressed what am i thinking about here
and think of it this way we have
maximized the activity of the rooks
excellent i'm thinking about the move f4
breaking through and creating a past
pawn not just any pass spawn a pass pawn
that is essentially going to be born on
g5
and in conjunction with a rook that cuts
off the king along the seventh rank you
have to understand that a past pawn is a
terrifying force rooks are second to
none
in
in in supervising
the progress of past pawns that's a very
important thing to understand
so we play the move f4
we try to compel him to take
and then we shove this pod forward as
far as it'll go g5 g6 and hopefully g7
g8
what we're also trying to do the reason
we're operating with such a sense of
urgency is that black is currently very
passive look at his bishop it's staring
at the pawn look at the rook on c8 it's
not a very good rook it's staring at the
pawn on c3 but that's not doing much our
rook on d3 is doing a perfectly good job
of defending that pawn on c3 so we're
trying to take this opportunity to push
this pass pawn as far as it'll go before
black has had a chance to consolidate
what's the evaluation here white is
definitely still losing i have no
no doubt that with accurate play
black can consolidate and win
but it's already become
so much more difficult to do that than
it was
even a couple of moves ago 94.
well what should we do now
what should we do now
we close our eyes and we play this move
we push the pawn of course very good we
play g6
king of fate nope that's a good move
let's think
i need to think
let's break this down let's understand
what's going on
what does black want
if it were black to move here what would
he do
what is black's threat
black wants to take rook takes e3 in my
opinion black wants to take on c3 with
the rook and as i'll show you guys after
the game
um the issue with those types of
positions is that we will be left with
only one pawn and that one pawn
well we'll be left with the second pawn
on a2 but that's not a very serious one
and i'm really afraid that that pawn on
g6 is going to be restrained
successfully by black's king
because if we play g7 the king just
steps aside to g does that make sense
so if we play rook f3
then after rook takes c3 check we have
to trade
and i'm just not convinced that that
resulting position is totally winning
for us in fact i don't know how to
evaluate it i feel like it's quite
unclear
we have interesting options there but if
black plays accurately i think you
should be totally fine
so then the question arrives well can we
defend the pawn on c3 can we prevent
rook takes e3 from happening we can
we can do that by unpinning the king and
playing king b2 these are the kinds of
moves that win games it's the moves the
patient moves that keep the tension in
the position
right not only does this keep the
tension this improves our position
because rook takes c3 even if it does
happen is never going to come with check
again
so we're attacking the pawn on d7
we're threatening rook f3 rook takes f4
as you guys were all indicating
and we're keeping the tension in the air
as much as possible and there we go
there's the blunder
the tension kills there's the blunder
that blunders a piece
and uh why does that blender a piece
well there's a pawn on g7 what square is
this pawn controlling it's controlling
the square on f7 what can go to f7 a
rook what does this do this forks the
king and the knight boom we take the
knight we still have some work left to
do
okay now i know that most of you are
probably going to be tempted by the move
rook f7 check
but wait a minute
am i ready to give up this g6 spawn that
easily
absolutely not so therefore i know you
guys are now thinking of the move rick
d6
but i'm actually thinking of a third
move here's what i see
what i see is that if the king takes the
pawn on g6
essentially the king is going to be one
file away from getting ladder checkmated
let's imagine that the pawn on f4 was
gone
do you guys see what happens after rook
takes f4
king takes g6
what happens black gets ladder
checkmated this is a classic ladder mate
we go rook g3 check and all we need to
do after king h5 is get this f rook
away from h4 we can go rook f1 we can go
rook f7
um and essentially the game is over well
we can do this in a variety of ways
uh if we want to be like super
incredibly accurate
i would go rook f2 rather than rook f1
or i would go rook f7 because rook f1
maybe black still has the move d4 in
order to open up the bishop and defend
h1
uh so so accuracy until the end
rook f7 is good rook f2 is good
i don't think it really matters i'm
going to go rook f2
now black and stave off mate with the
move rook c4
intending rook h2 check rook h4
he goes king h4 that's great now we need
to move this rook where do we move it
and the rule of thumb is that you want
to move your rooks as far away from the
king as possible and you also want to
keep the rook active so rather than just
going back to g1
why don't we squeeze the most out of
this move and go rook g7
and this is kind of like a life
insurance policy if you fail to give the
ladder mate for whatever reason
you can always still capture the pawn on
d7 and win the game just by vacuuming up
all of the queen side pawns we're also
up material
okay
what to do now
now we need to continue over extending
black's forces
rook f6 not quite not rook f6
well
i feel like let me think about this for
a second rook f6 there's rook c6
rook f6 there's rook c6
i'm going to play a very tricky move
check
i'm really hoping for king h2 by the way
if he goes back to h4 we'll repeat moves
but this sets a trap
you know actually yeah i mean the
problem is i thought rook f5 wins the
game here but i guess he's got rookie
chait
i guess he's got rookie chain i missed
it i missed her kate shade yeah
and i made a mistake because rick takes
d7 he's got bishop c8 now with a pin
so what do we do
we just don't quite have enough pieces
to deliver the ladder made but something
some pieces feeling lonely
there is a piece here that's feeling
lonely
there's a piece here that's saying hey
your rooks aren't uh
successfully accomplishing this task
what about the king
black is totally tied down there's
nothing that black can do here let's get
the king in
notice that i didn't play king c2 which
would have allowed d4 with the idea of
forking the king and the rook with
bishop before check we go through c1 we
go through the dark squares that's a
good rule of thumb when your opponent
has a bishop of only one color left
especially if you're in time trouble try
to put
your pieces on the other color square
particularly your rook this is a lot
more complicated than it looks a lot
let's go to d2
i mean we're trying to win this like
quickly and
i'll be honest i didn't expect uh black
to resist this long
and what we might end up doing if black
plays rook g3 here is just trading rooks
and winning the game just by taking all
of black's queenside bonds
okay bishop c6
let's keep going
well again
if we keep going we give up the pawn on
c3
it's the fastest mate here
let's go rook g5
i'm going to create a i'm going to
create a trap
i'm hoping for a move like a5
do you guys see what i'm preparing
yeah rook g2 checking h1 roxy one check
and then rook back to i want this rook
away from h3 so that i could keep
pushing my king forward
no black is
oh and that
oh it's so close to me rook g2 check
forces king h1 because king h3 there's
rook g3 mate
but um i think we can take this
opportunity
and just bring our king forward just get
our king further further
closer to f2
we continue to tighten the screws very
patiently
now eventually black will blunder
something here i mean he's defending
like caruana right now
the bishop is blocked at d4 check is
possible but then we're going to take
that pawn
okay i'm sure i missed a faster win but
ultimately we're
we're playing decent moves i think that
i'm i never really let this let this out
of my reach
in one of my own blitz games i would
have won this in a different way i
wouldn't have even bothered with the
ladder mate i would have essentially
forced a rook trade is what i would have
done
that's another great move wow
essentially preparing to give me side
checks
let's give him a check
see where the king goes
he is defending this amazingly well and
here king h3 loses i'm pretty sure he
has to go king down h1
i mean he's playing as well as he can
play
uh but it's still completely lost that's
the thing
i don't think that he's gonna survive
this for much longer
because after king h1
we can
get our king okay he goes king h3
and i want to show you guys a very
important ladder made technique what do
we do now who sees it
i think we're very very close to
delivering checkmate
we need to get our king
down to g1 in order to prepare rook h2
checkmate do you see how we involve our
king in that way
so we go king f2 we go king f2 we're
threatening rook g3 check and rook h2
mate
and we're also threatening king ju1
followed by rook h2 mate he's probably
going to give us a check on f6 and then
we talk our king on g1 and finally we
have hit paydirt because rock h2 is
going to be unstoppable
smart
right
d4 doesn't defend against the first
threat folks
d4 doesn't defend against the first
threat which is rook down to g3 check
king h4 with h2 mate why couldn't we do
this previously because previously the
rook on g3 would have been undefended as
it stands we have brought our king to f2
for the specific reason of guarding the
g3 square
does that make sense
down to g3 check
out h2 with mate and there we go there's
the full recovery
what a game
that was a really really tough one
i hope you guys enjoyed it um i
certainly did that was a lot that was a
lot of fun for me too because it's this
really presents a challenge for me i
have to very seriously
con you know
i have to play accurately because we
really don't have much margin for error
now this was hilarious e6 so by the way
what's funny about the way he played in
the opening is that this knight c66
thing was played against me many years
ago
in a game that i have shown champ with
the five subs let's go
loving it uh this was played against me
in one of my shortest ever tournament
games which i managed to win oh my
goodness we are i'm getting drowned with
subs right now muradane with the sub go
heels
uh and i want to show you guys this game
again i've shown it on stream many many
times
13 move game
precisely in this line
and this basically shows how white
actually should play against this line
so 2005 and i practice what i preach i
played the alpine
really all throughout the start of my
chess career as i told you guys up until
the time i was around 1900
if i were combat thank you for the seven
months 100 bits from with supreme
okay there you go there's e6 you see
now what should white actually do here
well white should just develop knight f3
knight c3 and in this position my
opponent played a fatal mistake believe
it or not
bishop e7 this loses the game
immediately
who can tell me why
wow it was 17 years ago that sounds
crazy
this looks like a nonchalant developing
move i mean how bad could this be
boom d5
okay well what's the big deal my
opponent takes on d5
and swings the knight up to b4
d6
the pawn i mean any time this happens
this is almost always deadly because if
the bishop drops back you have queenie
to check
and uh
that's it
the
bishop has to return to e7
um my opponent
makes a very miserable attempt at you
know trying to survive he plays bishop
takes d6
zeo thank you for the tier one
i take it
this is the least scary fork
of all time
and after bishop c4
uh the rook is coming to you and just
look at this position
94.
rookie won
i didn't even take the night i played
rookie one straight away because of the
pin and my opponent resigned here i mean
it's over rook takes e4 is coming next
if f5 then knight takes e4 fv rook takes
e4 with checkmate
i mean just totally crushing
so this shows you how dangerous the open
can be against you know this kind of
casual play
um
and that's how you should actually play
against this line
now here of course we
decided to make the genius move bishop
g5 and follow it up with an even more
genius move bishop
basics that's why the accuracy was so
low
yeah
so we immediately started the recovery
process by going e5 posing concrete
problems i'm going to fast forward to
the first interesting moment
yeah so queen h5 this is an idea and
again
using chess space i can probably find
for you guys
an example of this idea being applied in
a high level game without a piece being
sacrificed
tuka against capo blanca
in a simul a game which uh jose will
lose it loses now it's funny because in
the french there is a line where white
literally goes for this idea e5
h6 this is the mccutcheon bishop d2 is
the main line
and uh white plays ef6 this is the old
school line a fg7 and there you go queen
h5
queen f6 just like we had emilio thank
you for the sub and after queen takes g7
guess what white plays how does white
open up the king side h4
exactly as we did takes takes
knight c6 castle's long
rook f4
okay white is obviously not you know
super strong and i wonder how capoblanco
lost this game because at this point
already capoblanca is in great shape
oh
he blundered
i mean he blundered several times so
here white finds a very very nice move
who sees it
white found a very very pretty idea here
that all of a sudden starts turning the
table turning the tables
94
94 this forks the bishop and the queen
this forces capoblanca to take allowing
the queen into the game 92
and now queen f4 another blunder
amazing tactic by white again
what did dwight do in this position
i mean this is so cool white plays 94 on
move 22
and now guess what white does again
knight takes e4
you can't take because of bishop f3
skewering the queen to the checkmate
queen has no squares look at this pawn
on a3 if this pawn was on a2 black would
have queen b4
defending b7
can't do it here significance of every
pawn and piece that's why it's so
important to make luft because in
addition to making looks you're
controlling before that could be an
important square kappa blanca goes back
to f5 panics
boom takes takes and here white can take
the knight with an extra piece but even
stronger as queen d4 and couple blanco
resigned
this is how he lost a simul game white
was probably like 16 1700 those players
could be dangerous in a
okay so queen this was in a simul yeah
kabab blanco would not lose to him in a
normal game
so h4 opening up the king side
and obviously i castled here i didn't
mean to do that
of course we should have played knight
f3
here i think it would be a lot more
plausible that white black takes on g2
and after we castle
what is white's threat here
well white's threat is to play rook g1
and skewer the queen to the rook
um
and if black continues grabbing pawns
with queen takes f2 this is probably
winning for black
this is probably um winning for black
but
you know we can play knight i guess
knight g5 gets forked 23.
yeah in fact i think this is how black
should play black should just grab all
the pawns maybe we can go d5 here and
try to open up the center
actually this is really interesting
because if black tries to go rook g2 and
check made us we have create shade and
d6 me
um so it's situational completely
i mean luft is one of those things that
you want to do 90 of the time but you
want to do it when you have time and
when there are no greater priorities
what often happens is that you have
greater priorities throughout the game
and by the end you just didn't have time
to make lift and that's how
back rank stuff happens that's how bad
background stuff happens
it really depends on the situation so
in any case
uh
black didn't go queen takes you two and
he didn't
go queen g5 check which would have
forced the queen trade
what would i have done after the queen
trade i didn't have much in mind i mean
this is just completely losing
okay 97 knight f3 developing this should
be seven wolf just means air i think in
german and it just means a little hole
for the king
to avoid bat crank mate it doesn't just
mean a3 by the way that's a common
misconception
luft doesn't just mean h3 g3 or even h4
is also part of luft making loft
like lufthansa yeah the german airline
so knight e5
um
rook c8
rook up to d3 trying to swing into g3
and queen g5 check
so
in this position we go rock h7 this is
as good of an attempt as any and bishop
b4 essentially wins the game
what should white do if we face bishop
before well the only move here is rook
hhack
and after the rook drops back to g8
uh who can tell me how white at least
preserves some complexity in the
position
rook h3
but if you look very very carefully
black has a devastating tactic in
response black has a devastating tactic
in response
and this essentially wins the game for
black
how should you be thinking about this
well what you should see is that the
rook on h3 is overloaded
anytime you have a situation like this
where one piece is defending two
different things on opposite sides of
the board thank you v-dog for the sub
that's grounds for an overloading tactic
boom
and the second thing to notice is that
the knight on e7 is defending the c8
square that's crucial
if there was a rook on e7 you would be
you would have been checkmated on c8
okay we can play rook c7 here and hope
for a miracle but this is obviously
completely lost i mean black can do a
bunch of different things
uh
for instance black could even
you know black cake castle he's already
moved his king but we can go and move
like rook h2 and start picking off our
pawns
knights are amazing defenders that's
true
f6 is a big mistake and after knight f7
the margin for air the black head
shrinks tremendously
rook d5 was absolutely obligatory and as
we were discussing my move would have
been rook g3 trying to get the stroke as
active as possible as quickly as
possible get it to g7
get it to g7
uh a savage muffin asks an interesting
question
could we have could black have played
rook f5 as an alternative
to f6 the answer is no
the reason is that the rook when it
moves from g5 to f5 loses control of the
g8 square which then allows us to give
this check on h this is not mate and
after knight g8 in fact black is
probably still slightly better in this
end game but obviously this is like a
dream we've won the piece back
so f6 knight f7
and yeah rook d5 preserves a winning
advantage i'm sure of that and after
rook g3
how should black actually untangle it's
not so easy i mean i would have to think
about this for a while
black has already made his task very
very difficult
because
if black tries to cover the g7 square
with knight f5
then we have a beautiful tactical idea
we can give a check on ga
and after king e7 there is mate forced
mate in this position who sees it
i think you can see it you need to
consider all of the night
discover checks and see which one leads
to checkmate
95 95 is correct retreating night moves
the hardest moves to find in chess
nd6 and rook takes d7 me
right now you might be sitting there
particularly if you're a beginner how do
i find this quickly this is where you
just need to solve puzzles if you solve
puzzles you're going to get the hang of
these patterns and you're going to
eventually find these ideas
automatically that's just how it works
you can't think your way or learn your
way into finding these mates quickly you
just have to solve
this is the hook made yeah
so after knight f5 we take on g5
we won some material back and now the
move d5 blasting open the position
okay bishop d5 is impossible because of
this that's how i found the move oops
sorry
that's how i found the move i i
recognize that the bishop is tied down
to the rook
after he takes d5
congrats uh lucky after he takes d5 the
position opens up making it a lot harder
for black to focus his attention on our
king
g4 and now i think the game-winning move
is f4 this creates
problems for black that are incredibly
difficult to solve even for a very
strong player i mean already the
position is very complicated
and after 94 i think the crucial moment
g6f8 was here
this is where you just have to be
extremely patient identifying the threat
and by the way what happens if black
takes on c3 here
well here white has a very typical win
if the pawn is located diagonally from
the king like this
remember the idea of rook h8 check
because the king can't approach the pawn
and now you play g7 g8
but not the immediate g7 because of king
f7 the rook cannot move away without
giving up the pawn
okay you can't do this because black
just takes the plan you have to do it in
the other order
okay
um the engine says f4 is a huge blunder
ask me if i care
because i do not i feel like f4 is a
good practical move
we're in a situation where you know
perhaps the engine finds some sort of
uh better approach for white but i feel
like and i think you guys would agree
with me
i don't even see a defense for black
here so i feel like that's a good litmus
test for whether this is going to be a
good resource at you know at a 13 1400
level and i don't mean that
sarcastically i think it's totally valid
to analyze with an engine but at some
point this is part of the reason behind
the speed and i'm trying to get you guys
to see what kinds of options are
practically
are practically strong
okay so 94 g6 king f8 and after king b2
the blunder comes immediately knight f6
blunders the knight
on f6
what should black have done instead i
don't actually know see that's a case in
point maybe rook c6
maybe knight back around to g5
but then we just start vacuuming up
pawns we take d7 we can take a7
perhaps this is the this is the correct
approach though bishop c6 and then maybe
something like f3
and uh
maybe it turns out that black's pawn is
stronger than whites but
the the point and this is beyond the
scope of this particular game we have
done our job we've complicated the game
uh from a position where we were a piece
down
um
and after knight f6 we don't really have
to talk about this uh end of the game
guys i mean i tried to ladder checkmate
him
uh perhaps i had something more accurate
i honestly don't really feel like
digging into this i feel like we
basically played well
now what would i do in a classical game
i would seriously contemplate just
taking on d7 essentially and just
vacuuming up all the pawns right this is
probably even a simpler approach thank
you zenith sounds fine this is even a
simpler approach but i really wanted to
stick with the idea of giving laddermate
so that's why i kept trying to get my
rook to the age file rook 8 is actually
something i completely missed
all right now we send our king forward
king c1 king d2
rook g5 threatening this very typical
mating construction which you also have
to remember by the way this is important
as well anytime there's a piece on h3
usually a rook that blocks the king's
escape backward you have this mating
pattern
now we continue pushing our king forward
and guaranteeing passageway to g1
black should have gone king h1 this was
the last chance
and here
i
still was contemplating the move king f2
and after rook f6 check my final
question to you guys what is my idea
here what can white try to do
where should the king go
the blind swine mate yeah the king
should go to g3
threatening rook h7 threatening rook h2
and my guess is that we're very very
close to winning the game rook h6 and
now you can actually forget all about
the ladder mate and instead go for the
conventional probably riccito is better
because d1 is a light square it could be
guarded by the bishop but rook c2
threatens rook c1 and that is just
unstoppable
so combining all of these patterns is
also an important skill to have in these
situations
okay and that ends the game i mean in
the game he played king h3 we walk our
king back and deliver checkmate on h2
what about black d4 with pawn to open
bishop up asks holmes was here where
when he did that holmes
oh you mean at the end so in case of
king h1 king f2
oh yeah d4 here
oh yeah d4 here is a good move actually
but after rich you want king h2 we can
just play c takes d4
essentially we can take the pawn and
then kind of restart the process but
you're right this is probably black
specimen
he was too late opening up the bishop he
tried doing that but it was too late
this prevents king g1 but it doesn't
prevent the second me
man
what a game i think that was a
successful finally a successful attempt
to
uh to blunder a piece and i hope you
guys found that instructive i know that
this is a gap in the speed run because i
tend to get essentially winning
positions out of the opening every time
so hopefully
uh this was helpful and i'll definitely
do this again
maybe to a lesser extent
uh at at a higher level maybe i'll do
this again at 16 1700 and see if we can
somehow create enough complications to
beat someone at that level as well
all right guys thank you so much
appreciate all the support truly and
i'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]
you